good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways to keep
yourself motivated Plus who encourages
you who supports you when you have dark
days or maybe you don't have dark days
but when you're like oh I need someone
to pick me up I am you always have dark
days let's brown or black all right well
the I have a group of people you know I
believe in o QP only quality people you
have to have people around you that you
can learn from that you can grow from
and that people that will encourage you
and to have some friends that that tell
me less you can make it you can go
through this thing you can handle this
it's very important that we give
ourselves a support base and and people
around you that will make you stretch
remember of quote five gentlemen out of
Atlanta and he said that you're the
smartest one your group you need to get
a new group and that's the same they
give you the Strogatz what you've got to
get some other folk that's stronger than
you are in the various areas and that
can help you through so I have spiritual
partners I have social partners business
partners and they are my support group
that gives me a home court advantage in
this place called Earth and allow me to
bounce back when life knocks me down
because life catches all of us on the
Blind Side and so you got to have some
people that you can fall back on make
sure you're doing something you love you
don't need an excuse to do things you
love and so most people who need
motivation to work harder usually find
it's because they're working on
something they don't enjoy
so either scrap that or find something
you do enjoy you know there's a there's
an energy around focusing on your
passion that many people ignore but you
might be turning around to me and saying
well Peter I don't have a chance to do
that I'm stuck in this deal and I've got
this project I've got to finish and
there's so much to do how do I do it
well if you can't yeah follow your
passion and use that level of energy to
tap into giving yourself to work harder
then rent yourself out what I mean by
that you know seeing yourself as we
acted in that particular scene not every
scene in a movie if you're watching the
movie yet goes according to plan in
terms of how they the leader character
wants it to go so just know that you're
in that scene at this moment and rent
yourself out see yourself you know
offstage looking at yourself on screen
and just really just saying I'm just got
to go through these lines for this
particular part and that disassociates
us emotionally from a lot of the
negative vibrations that we attach to
what it is that we're doing if we feel
unmotivated
everybody's successful Laser blue for
now you laid a blueprint out uh you know
I can go down a list from comedians to
actors to entrepreneurs to self-made
moguls you look at Russell Simmons you
look at jay-z you look at Tyler Perry
you look at puffs I mean you're looking
at people that start off with a small
vision and that vision manifested into
something beyond expectation so what I
did was from the people around me my
mentors Eddie Murphy Chris Rock pride er
who are all on the wall all in walls so
you surround yourself with I surround
myself with a constant reminder of who's
great constantly I come down these steps
every day I look at Richard oh he's
great
I see Eddie he was great I see Chris
Rock he was great it's a constant
reminder what am I trying to achieve I
want to be great so that motivates me
choice your common sense will tell you
when you believe you have a sense of
autonomy a sense of choice in what
you're doing you feel more
self-motivated be if scooter taught us
that too in his book Beyond freedom and
dignity when he back in 1971 reading
that book changed my life because I
realized that I am controlled by
consequences but sometimes I don't feel
controlled when I'm working for a
pleasant consequence it feels good it
feels like I'm working to get something
when I'm working to avoid an aversive
consequence I feel controlled that's
called negative reinforcement so here's
a challenge leaders how do we get people
to become success seekers rather than
failure avoiders first day of
introductory psychology class I teach
two classes of 600 students maybe some
of you have been in that class and
remember the first day I say
how many are here to avoid failure at
80% razor head
I say well thanks for coming I know
you're motivated but you're not happy
campers you probably told your friends I
got to go to class it's a requirement
not I get to go to class it's an
opportunity you probably woke up to an
alarm clock not an opportunity clock and
it's all in how you see it
really it's all in how you see it it's
your paradigm it's how you communicate
to others and how you communicate to
yourself so Ellen Langer said in her
book mindfulness she said and
psychologists know when you perceive
choice you perceive motivation you're
more motivated so the deal is for
yourself sit back and reflect be mindful
of the choices you have and talk about
being a success Seager rather than a
failure of order it's all how you talk
how you communicate to yourself and to
others how do you stay focused motivated
and maintain enthusiasm where things
don't go the way you had hoped nothing
might my sort of drive to get it done is
somewhat disconnected from hope
enthusiasm or anything else I just I
actually just don't care about hope or
enthusiasm motivation I just give it
give it everything I've got
irrespective of what the circumstances
may be
you know there yeah you just keep going
I get it done so what do you think how
do you keep yourself motivated for me
most important is having positive people
in my life if anytime I'm having
difficulty I'm struggling with something
you know I go to my fiancee I go to my
one of my closest friends and I talk it
through and tends to you know lift my
spirits and that helps me sort of in
general day-to-day thinks that if I'm
having a hard day or whatnot
overall I actually I keep a small diary
believe it or not and so I record and
then I put little bookmarks you know on
the hard days and the good days and
sometimes I'll just read one of those
good days or I'll even go on Facebook
and I'll look at some pictures of myself
having fun you know doing something
crazy and you know that motivates me
right in general that motivates me I
love it that's it I've never heard
anybody say that I like it for me I
think it comes from a sense of one
knowing that what I'm doing is important
I want to reach people with the work
that I'm doing and so the YouTube
comments you guys are what keeps me
motivated on a regular basis every day
it's one of the first things I do every
morning is I'd load up my youtube
comments and see what people are saying
and it's always positive and amazing and
so that gives me juice and fire to want
to keep creating more amazing things for
you guys and then too I think creating
an environment that makes me excited and
builds me up so the top 10 series the
answer presto series I made selfishly
for myself and I'm so glad that you guys
you know enjoy it as well but I made
that for me so I wake up every day
surrounded by all these great leaders
and innovators and world changers and it
motivates me to want to do something
bigger and beyond what I'm currently
doing so I find that that really helped
thank you so much for watching we made
this video because Karolina martinez
asks us to if you have another topic in
mind for the believe life series leave
it in the comments below I'd also love
to know which of the videos that you saw
today really had the biggest impact on
you leave it in the comments we'll join
in the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon
and so the question is how do you keep
motivated and what I have found that
what really works for me it's a very
simple it's just if you eat a really
healthy breakfast you're going to be
feeling more energetic and positive and
and stronger all day if you eat a poor
breakfast or you don't eat breakfast at
all you're going to be weak and
irritable it's the same thing with
mental food so you take in a really good
breakfast and what I do is I have a good
high-protein breakfast but no
carbohydrates no bread no pasta no
muffins no rules no bagels just eggs
really high protein and maybe orange
juice now with regard to your mind I
rewrite my goals every morning we're
sort of set you off positively because
whenever you think about your goals you
become positive then I plan every day in
advance I make a list of everything I
have to do and set priorities and then I
start in on my most important tasks and
I work at my most important task in the
morning until it's complete and then go
on to task number two the next thing I
do is I listen to positive audio
programs in my car now this is so
important that when you feed your mind
with positive material as you're driving
around you tend to be a more positive
person so if you do those simple things
is get up in the morning eat well I
always exercise as I've told you before
eat a good breakfast rewrites four goals
before you start plan your day in
advance and start on your top priority
and when you move around listen to audio
programs the combination is like a rich
mental feast that keeps you positive and
energized all day long